okay I want to talk a little bit about
live calls I believe that it's basically
a crapshoot when we take live calls
sometimes we have really good calls
sometimes we have okay calls but I've
increasingly been getting messages from
people saying David I think you have
some of the worst callers in progressive
media and in fact there was a comment
that was made on reddit a new thread
where a user said the david pakman show
has some of the worst callers
unprogressive radio prepare what you're
going to say and be succinctly in about
this one person saying the call-in is my
least favorite part of the show I don't
know why but it's very rare to have a
caller make an interesting point or
question or for there to be a good
discussion another user on the subreddit
responding to this said I love Colin
talk shows I think David does a fine job
however a call screener would certainly
help to expedite the flow of the show
the screener could break the ice with
nervous callers give instructions and
weed out the dweebs also another comment
to be fair conservative radio shows tend
to have pretty awful callers as well so
I figure since we're doing the live
calls weekly I should say a little bit
about this we don't have the resources
in place for a call screener right now
but I I do agree with you that at a sort
of basic level the things that would
improve live calls are number one for
the caller to be prepared with their
question and off speakerphone number two
to have your question written down if
necessary right if you have any
ambiguity at all in terms of what the
question is going to be and how it's
going to be worded write it down and
number three get directly to the
question I find that one of the big
problems that causes people's eyes to
glaze over is when there's two minutes
of lead up to what the question is get
right to the question and I see live
calls sort of as like a varial variable
reward system it's sort of what makes
social media addicting when you check
Facebook or Twitter you might have some
exciting new notifications or you might
not you might have some messages from a
friend or you might not it's
the same thing with live calls we go to
each call it could be a dud or it could
be a great call that sometimes is one of
the most watched clips on our entire
youtube channel for the week the other
thing is that our calls sadly are a tiny
fraction of all the callers we get like
we usually have time for 8 to 10 calls
20 30 or even 40 people end up either
hanging up because they're on hold too
long or we end up ending calls before we
get to them there's really nothing I can
do about that I mean I can't make I
can't take 3 hours of calls every single
day so I'm open to ideas about how to
handle this issue the this I think that
calls are also a good way for people who
insist on quote debating me on social
media we can say hey just call in and
make your point we have an opportunity
for you to speak directly to me so I
think that the calls have problems but
they've also resulted in some really
really great segments yeah I'd like to
see the calls continue they're great for
community engagement I like seeing those
debates and sometimes the audience
members have really fascinating question
it does happen but we got to up the
quality I think yeah and and I think
it's really a resource issue at its core
and so I'm open to ideas from people we
will continue taking calls hopefully
some people will at least see my three
tips for calls be off speakerphone know
your question and get right to the
question and maybe we'll comment about
this a little bit more on today's bonus
show which of course you can access as
both a member and a patron of the David
Pakman show when you're setting up your
website there are a few important things
to keep in mind first keep all of your
domains in the same place you won't have
to jump around to different places to
keep everything in order and if you need
to update them you can do it all at once
in the same place second keep your
hosting and your domain separate if
something ever goes wrong with your web
host and you need to find a new one and
you've registered your domain with your
host transferring your domain can be a
huge time consuming and confusing hassle
keeping your host and domain separate
also creates another layer of security
even if hackers get a hold of your files
your domain will still be safe if it's
registered elsewhere
this is what's great about hover which
is a fantastic domain hosting service
that makes all of this possible
you can keep your domain somewhere
separate from your actual website which
makes managing a website much more
convenient and safe hover also has great
prices and they won't try to upsell you
they have hundreds of domain extensions
and they'll give you personalized email
addresses that match your domain they
provide a nice clean user interface
that's incredibly easy to use and their
support team is one of the best in the
business if you're setting up a website
or looking to transfer your domain keep
your domain separate from your host and
check out hover you can go to hover.com
slash Pakman for 10% off your first
order at checkout use the promo code
Pakman that's PA que ma n